[Music]
foreign
ER steal power on osiris-4 and thinking
yeah we should rule exactly like him
when we take over
[Music]
yeah claiming people will receive a fair
trial while dragging a body with at
least 17 knives stuck in it really
screams do process did it make you feel
better I'm sure nobody was happy about
making such a terrible decision but put
desperate people in a situation where
they have to do awful things to get the
bare necessities of life and don't be
surprised when they do those things they
didn't sell out their friends for a flat
screen TV food and Medicine are vital
find a sellout Jeremy to get a burger
and fries from Five Guys you bet your
ass I'd give him to fedra people gotta
eat completely unrelated let's take this
time to announce our newest TV soon
sponsor your informers inform well I do
hate to side with the midwestern
desperate here I've gotta admit their
hesitation doesn't make sense there are
some humans that could stand on
principle even at the cost of their life
but in a room this size there would be
at least one person with a hand
immediately in the air begging to give
up any and all info damn Melanie
linsky's come a long way from sneaking
into Charlie Sheen's bedroom though I
guess after 12 seasons of Two and a Half
Men I might be driven to Insanity enough
to attempt to build an authoritarian
regime as well when you're done burn the
bodies it's faster faster than what I
guess fires a bit faster than the corpse
barrels on breaking bad but in a world
where mushrooms possess people burning
bodies isn't the faster option it's the
only option 20 cans and six pounds of
directly for the three of us
if we stick to the minimum I think we
can make it 11 Days please I put away
six pounds of jerky in 11 minutes so I
guess we all know who isn't going to
survive the apocalypse
we're great they'll make an excellent
permanent addition to the cast but
grabbing a pack of crayons and a gun
with no ammo and it doesn't say a lot
for Henry's ability to prioritize
i-beams who dreams of having superpowers
and starts with [__] eye Beams I
don't want to poke holes in Henry's plan
but personally if I had 11 days worth of
food I'd have spent it getting 11 days
away from this painting in an
unventilated attic
kids
it's a sweet gesture and a confidence
booster but how confident is Henry that
that pain is safe for using on skin this
seems like a rash decision they didn't
hurt you so you don't hurt us right
that's right so we're [__] tall man
that's just the way he sounds he has an
[__] voice Joe telling he's okay
everything is great dude I love
everything about this Joel and Ellie are
great together but adding Henry and Sam
to this Dynamic chef's kiss I'm just
glad this isn't some cruel game by the
show to completely destroy us by the end
of the episode right we didn't hurt you
so you hurt us right pointing a gun at
someone and not admitting it might cause
emotional or psychological harm it's
home man tone policing the man you're
holding at gunpoint
as much as I love this scene and Ellie I
think she's maybe being a bit too chill
here while being held at gunpoint who's
her dad season 4 Walter White would you
get these from Bill he's dead I thought
Joel was the awkward one hey Ellie nice
sweater where'd you get it from my Nana
she has dementia
I've heard that in a long time look at
this so wholesome it even warms the cold
dead cockles of my heart I'll puke
afterward of course but at least I've
got the whole warmed up cockles thing
going on now I'm sitting how hard Henry
is pushing on that pencil writing
utensils are a bit of a commodity in the
apocalypse he's up on that graphite all
these highways surrounding Downtown
Kansas City are technically accurate
Interstate 35 also makes up the western
boundary which you've left blank if
you're gonna draw and label a map fill
the whole thing out don't have ass two
things whole ass one thing Henry Kansas
City is a Subway not just a Subway
several Subways more than 20 and there's
also a Quiznos Blimpy and a Firehouse
Subs you really should do more research
you notice anything strange about the
city no infected the city
series just wait that joke will kill in
about four episodes in fact you drove
them underground 15 years ago how the
[__] did they manage that and why can't
the other Federal districts replicate it
indoor
and and survive roll commercials I know
he's only eight but that was some
pathetic goalkeeping we're not doing so
good we maybe the search would go better
if you were helping instead of sitting
up in your childhood room doing nothing
he would be horrified by the things I've
done and if you've come to tell me that
Michael wouldn't want me to hurt Henry
that he would want me to forgive I know
that too just in case you saw Kathleen
order the murder of a room full of
prisoners and thought hmm maybe there's
still some good in her here's her I know
I'm wrong and evil and I don't care
speech No One's Gonna be here because my
plan worked premature celebration
[Music]
member sniper this comically bad was he
a stormtrooper in another life leaving
your back door unlocked while you're
sniping that's how spies break in and
backstab you and even if you've got a
Razorback equipped they can still just
headshot you while your eyes in the
scope thinking you can spin fast enough
to shoot a man who's not only several
decades younger than you but is
absolutely draped in plot armor
Anthony had known about Joel's crew for
maybe two minutes at most and to get
from downtown Kansas City to that point
would take long enough that they could
Escape across the river unless of course
they move it season 7 Gendry speed
really is a testament to the rig on
Stark School of running away from things
that their campus not only survived the
apocalypse but continued to graduate
students all the same well done you guys
well this is what happens when you [__]
with fate I'm not sure that this
happened to any character with Dr Fate
and I watched Justice League Unlimited
Young Justice and Black Adam
foreign
maimed and monologued your way through
Kansas City the man who betrayed your
brothers right in front of you and your
gun is drawn oh look vengeance is at
hand but wait that flaming truck just
sank under the ground that's weird huh I
could shoot Henry and then turn but nah
this deserves all of my attention also a
sinkhole that's a shame Really Gonna
lower the value of that property it'll
just be that much harder for a hedge
fund to turn the house into six
apartments and charge triple the market
rate for rent they'll only be able to
charge double now
leaving your chores undone that people
always come back to bite you eventually
zombie show remembers how to zombie
retreating as soon as fungus face showed
up you're like three feet away from
vehicles and 20 feet away from several
houses you could fortify
didn't he just reload it's nice of him
to still run out of ammo for dramatic
effect though
oh no Henry's gone from hiding behind
automobiles to hiding under them I love
Henry and Sam but their survival
instincts are complete [__] and they're
just absolute trash at hide and seek
how the hell did Kathleen make it across
the entire chaos filled Battlefield
unscathed just think of all the cars she
must have had to hide behind for someone
so hellbent and focused on Revenge that
she literally sacrificed her entire city
she is very easily distracted from said
Revenge oh no someone's being murdered
by an infected let's stop and stare
because the same thing hasn't been
happening for the last 20 minutes you
know what herding infected was probably
easier than getting these three to move
consistently in a straight line look I
don't know exactly how I'm getting to
Wyoming I'm probably walking but if you
want to eat yeah yeah I think it'd be
nice for Sam to have a friend let's
touch and go there for a while and they
never passed up an opportunity to
stupidly hide behind a car but I'm
relieved Henry and Sam made it I look
forward to this becoming their trademark
skill in season two
thinking either of these kids is going
to sleep after the [__] they've
witnessed this evening
well that's a weird question for him to
ask oh no I know you did not introduce
this adorable and lovable character just
to kill him off in a single episode
because that would be cruel and would
prevent me from getting attached to any
other characters for the length of the
series that's right your attempt to make
me care has made me care less you played
yourself show also Joel and Henry
foregoing a bike check after that huge
battle seems like a big oversight that
neither of them would have made
his medicine okay that's a relief
Ellie's immune it's the whole point of
the show so now I'm sure she'll be able
to save Sam this couldn't be another and
even more manipulative and cruel trick
by the show Runners right hey no one is
more eager to save Sam than me but why
is she cutting the palm of all the
places to cut you choose somewhere
highly sensitive often dirty and it will
take forever to heal maybe it looks
dramatic on camera but for once it'd be
nice to see what common sense looks like
all right problem solved you had me go
in there for a second The Last of Us now
time for bed and more death defying
harrowing adventures in the morning wait
why does Cindy keep adding sins instead
of taking them away
uncapable promises look at these two
best friends for life cannot wait to see
the spin-off
you are really confusing me what the
hell man hey
why didn't he say hey back he's
obviously awake that's just rude oh and
apparently that's the end of the episode
wait why is this still going Cindy just
keeps muttering something about me being
a Wim concern for my well-being
something about Phoebe from Friends
being old and yelling I can't figure it
out anyway not sure why I'm still here
or why the credits seem to have jumped
in so suddenly oh well Last of Us
remains my favorite show and I love how
it makes me feel Long Live Jewel at
least Sam and Henry
hey Travis what you doing with that gun
did it make you feel better did it make
you feel safe how does it make you feel
now these kids
like all of us
are a part of a community
what is it with you kids every other day
it's food food
[Music]
this was actually just a big wooden box
a big wooden box that nothing could get
inside of what's in the box